hello everyone this story happened some
10 years ago me and my friend were
playing chess in a bar and we were
playing blitz games for like maybe three
or four hours and well when we were done
with playing chess my friend left the
bar and I stayed for one more one more
drink and well the chessboard was still
there on the bar and the this person
arrived and he asked me if I wanted to
play a game of chess with him and I
looked at him and he seemed well he
wasn't drunk but he was drunk ish and I
said well yeah sure okay let's let's
play a game and he said like well okay
let's play a game but for $20 and well
at that time $20 so was was a lot of
money for me so I was pretty skeptical
about accepting his offer and well I
thought about it and I looked at him you
know I thought he probably isn't some
some kind of a master or anything as I
do live in a small town so I'd probably
know if there was a master in in the
town I live in so I accepted his offer
and we started playing I had the white
pieces and that he was black so I played
efore he responded with a 5
I played Knight to f3 and here he played
f6 and well it was in this position that
actually I got very nervous because well
obviously if someone plays f6 you're
just gonna capture Knight captures on e5
f captures here and then Queen to h5
check and maybe g6 and then Queen
captures on e5 winning the rook on h8
for example but the reason I got nervous
when he played this f6 move is because
well this does exist in just theory this
is called the damiano defense this is a
defense named by the Portuguese master
Pedro Damiano and as this knife chapters
on e5 is the Damiano gambit or I think
in Portuguese it's even called gambit oh
the bastard or something like something
like that and well knife captures on e5
isn't the best move here the best move
here is Bishop to c4 or Knight to c3 can
be played but
my captors ne5 isn't to the best move
and I started looking looking at my
opponent and I thought is he trying to
trick me
because if I play tonight captures any
fun he has this Queen to e7 move and
well then white doesn't really I mean
white is still better of course but he
does have to play a game because Knight
Queen to h5 trick doesn't work here
because after g6 you don't have this
Knight captures and g6 option because
Queen captures on e4 with Czech and
after Bishop to e2 Queen captures
tonight on g6 white is down a piece and
black is winning this game but after
this f6 move I did capture the pawn on
e5 as I I thought now he doesn't know
anything about chess he doesn't know
what the damiano defenses and well the
most famous famous occurrence of this
opening was actually in 1964 mr. Robert
MacGregor actually played this f6 idea
against Bobby Fischer as Fischer was
holding a simultaneous exhibition and
well Fischer did play Knight captures on
e5 and he got this response Queen to e7
and the Robert MacGregor was able to
drew the draw a game against the Bobby
Fischer so in this game I played Knight
captures an e5 but of course my opponent
did not play Queen to e7 he played F
captures on e5 I played Queen to h5
check he didn't put g6 he played King to
e7 and well at this point I knew that my
opponent wasn't really a good chess
player so I went Queen captures any five
check he went King to seven Bishop to c4
check now he didn't even push d5 plating
to g6 and well Queen to a5 check King to
h6 now d4 opening a discover check from
the bishop and c1 we have G 5 here I
pushed h4 and after Bishop to e7 I just
captured it's an it's check from the
pawn and from the rook on h1 King to g7
and Queen to f7 and this is checkmate so
ok my opponents congratulated me and
well I refuse to take his money because
it was a the game was too easy I mean to
take someone $20 but then actually he
insisted we play another game and I
thought well why do you want to play
another game I mean you just lost the
game in like 11 moves what's what's your
deal and then I thought okay maybe maybe
he really is a master and he's hustling
me and I thought now he was gonna
suggest we playing for I don't know
maybe $40 or 50 but actually he said no
no let's play for for $10 and okay I I
accepted his offer and we started
playing I had the black pieces and I
don't remember the game I remember it
was a Scandinavian defense I also won
the game in like 12 moves and he just
dropped the other $10 and he left he
joined he joined his friends at the bar
and continued our continued drinking
beer so yeah this is this is the story
of how I won thirty dollars this is the
this is actually the only money I ever
won playing chess and that was ten years
ago so yeah that definitely has
something to remember so yeah I would
like to thank Gregory vice Thomas
grilling Vince oceania Barry and Levi
[ __ ] for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
and yeah as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon